the questions were useless it was nice
to get to know these people I mean my
reputation's on the line you know I see
I see the YouTube comments I know what
people expect out of me they think I'm
this you know genius that just is never
wrong that's a lot of pressure I'm a
great man I do a lot of great things but
I'm not perfect but I think maybe Becky
ate my sandwich
I definitely ate your sandwich of course
you did got the eyes of a panther it's
tough it's tough to face you down I
guess I know the shape of Becky's mouth
because I that that was one of my major
influencers as well or maybe I'm just
that good I don't know but uh that's us
thinking it was hard look at the toss-up
man it's a one out of four toss-up but I
got it I got it right I was right
[Applause]